welcome back in the last presentation I
showed you how to essentially reverse
the chain rule when you're doing an
integral and you could also do this by
integral
it's called integration by substitution
and I'll show you why and this is
essentially just a reverse of the chain
rule the last problem we did in that
last video I said sine of X to the third
power times cosine of X and I took the
integral of the whole thing and I did it
kind of you know just telling you that
well we're just reversing the chain rule
so we we see the derivative of the sine
X here right which is cosine of X so we
can just treat sine of X like a variable
and take its integral and I just say
that that is equal to sine of X to the
fourth times 1/4 right and the reason
why we could just treat the sine of X
like it's just like kind of a variable
instead of a function is because we had
its derivative sitting right here and if
you think if you keep doing it back and
forth between the chain rule and what I
just did I think it'll make a lot of
sense so this Y I have been a little
confusing so I'll show you a technique
called integration by substitution which
is essentially the exact same thing so
let's start with this exact same
integral here and let's pretend like we
don't know the answer we say well we
have kind of a we have a function and
it's derivative so let me let you let's
let you let u is equal to the function
that we have the derivative of right let
u is equal to sine let let u U is equal
to sine of X right and U as sine of X
well what's what's the derivative of u D
u DX D u DX well we know what D u DX is
right
D u of DX is equal to cosine of X we
memorize that and then I will maybe in a
future presentation I'll actually prove
it to you so what we can now do is
substitute these two things into this
equation into this into integral so the
integral now becomes instead of writing
sine of X to the third power we can
right you to the third flower and what's
cosine of X well we just showed cosine
of X is just d u DX right so it's x d u
DX and then we have x DX right and I
know you're probably not too not too
comfortable with differentials at this
point but they behave and just the way
regular numbers do with the fraction so
this DX and this DX actually do cancel
out and you're left with that this is
equal to the integral of U to the third
D U and now this is an easy integral the
only thing different than what you might
have seen recently is that instead of an
X we have au here well we know the
answer of this integral well that this
is just is equal to 1/4 U to the fourth
and then of course we should add the
plus C are we done well I mean almost
but it would be nice to just take that
you and unwind it and put the sine of X
back in for it so let's do that so U is
just sine of X that's what we said in
the beginning 1/4 sine of X to the
fourth plus C done actually this might
be an easier way to think about these
type of integrals than what I did in the
last presentation but you know every now
and then you have to bear with me I do
things in the wrong order let's do a
couple more problems like this let's
take the integral of
2 X plus 3 times x squared plus 3 X plus
15 to the fifth power DX that looks
complicated to you doesn't it well just
like we said this is a pattern like we
saw in the previous example we have this
this function this this expression here
x squared plus 3x plus 15 and well
what's the derivative of this x squared
plus 3x plus 15
well it's 2x plus 3 okay now notice that
I've engineered it so it works cleanly
but most textbooks and tests tend to do
that so let's make the substitution
because we have a you that we can use
and then we have this derivative right
so we can say u is equal to x squared
plus 3x plus 15 and we can say then the
derivative of U I mean we know the
derivative of U is 2x plus 3 right
because the derivative 15 is 0 so now we
can make our substitutions and I'm just
going to switch the orders of these two
around no different so this is just u to
v right because this is this so this is
just u to v u to v and then this is d u
DX times D u DX right I just I just
switched the orders and then I multiply
that times DX and these cancel out I
know you're not completely comfortable
yet with even this integration notation
why this DX was sitting there in the
first place but when we do the definite
integrals to make more sense but this is
just equal to the integral of U to the
fifth D you on the integral of this well
this is easy this is just equal to one
sixth U to the sixth right plus C and
now we can just unwind this I'll do it
up here to make it extra
see this is just equal to 1/6 times you
which is this right here right we just
set you to equal this expression 1 6x
squared plus 3x plus 15 all of this to
the 6th power plus C let's do one more I
think we have time for one more image
clear image image invert okay I will
also switch colors just to keep just to
keep things interesting let's take the
integral of e to the x times e to the X
to the fifth I keep using it let's say
to the minus 3rd power DX well once
again we have this expression e DX and
what's the derivative of e to the X well
the derivative of e to the X is we
learned which is one of these things
that really amazes me is is e to the X
actually that's one definition for e is
the number which to that when 2 raised
to the X power it's the derivative is
the same expression but anyway I don't
want confuse you too much but we can say
then that U is equal to e to the X and
we know that D U DX is equal to e DX as
well which is once again mind-blowing so
if we rewrite this top integral this is
just equal to I won't switch this time
so this is d u DX right D u DX times U
to the minus 3 DX I don't know what
you're thinking Sal well do you DX is e
to the X U is also DX why didn't I
substitute it the other way around why
didn't I say this why didn't I say that
this one is U and why didn't I say why
didn't I say this one is why didn't I
say that this one is D you
DX to the minus three here well as you
can see this would have been useless
right because then I can't multiply it
times the DX and it gets all confusing
and and actually I just realized I mean
I've constructed a very silly problem
for you because you could simplify this
before even doing it with substitution
but well we'll continue doing it with
substitution but anyway as you see if
you did it in this way it becomes very
complicated so we don't want to do it
like that so this as we see simplifies
to the integral of U to the minus three
D U and that that equals let's see you
raise the exponent 1 minus 1/2 U to the
minus 2 and then that's the same thing
as minus 1/2 e to the X to the minus 2
or we could view that as minus 1/2 e to
the minus 2x and of course plus C at the
end now why did why was my problem that
I gave you silly well I could have
simplified this before even doing the
substitution right I could have said
that that's the same thing as the
integral of e to the x times e to the
minus 3x DX which is the same thing as
the integral of e to the minus 2x DX and
actually well it's good that I did it by
substitution because this probably
wouldn't have been completely intuitive
for you to do just yet as well but
anyway that's integration by
substitution I might do another
presentation where I do slightly harder
problems but using this same technique
I'll see you soon